we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is
pretty funny last week we had a
voicemail that I didn't really
understand which said hey David is the
entire Bernie Sanders thing a
distraction and I wondered which thing
and a distraction from what we have now
someone following up who is concerned
about another distraction on the program
take a listen to this hi David this is
Michael from Missouri I wanted to just
call and ask you about the whole
producer Pat thing I mean do you think
that it's a distraction
thanks yeah you know I do think that the
entire producer Pat thing is a huge
distraction and that's why we're going
to be asking him about it on today's
bonus show where we will discuss there
is a growing movement that says TV
producers are doing something ethically
wrong by putting Rudy Guiliani on TV
because he just lies that's all he does
Joe Biden is one of those people we will
talk about that we will also talk about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails now you're probably thinking I'm
kidding I'm not kidding
the Trump administration is now in the
wake of the impeachment inquiry in the
wake of being caught red-handed not even
saying that they were trying to collude
as an understatement
forcing collusion with Ukraine they are
now ramping up an investigation into
Hillary Clinton's emails it is still
going on we will also talk about a very
interesting interview with former
British Prime Minister David Cameron who
is calling the brexit referendum that
led to everything we have seen since
January 23 2016 the day of that vote his
greatest regret and it still is not
clear in fact it is sort of more and
more clear it's unclear that brexit is
going to happen you could also argue it
is more clear that it is not going to
happen but we'll have that conversation
on the bonus show all of those stories
and more including the distraction of
producer Pat as the voicemail caller
said on today's bonus show two ways to
get access become a member at join
pakman.com become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
remember you can call the voicemail
number
four hours a day and many of you do the
number of voicemails we get between like
2:00 and 5:00 a.m. Eastern Time is is
high it's very very high two one nine
two david p is the number and i hope you
will join me this evening for a live
stream on twitch at twitch.tv slash
david pakman follow me subscribe there
with twitch prime and i hope you'll join
me this evening